[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياض في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
البدايه من رام الله وتوتر بالضفه الغربيه
بعد ان قتلت قوه الاحتلال فلسطينيه خلال
اقتحامها مخيمه نور شمس في طولكرم
ثم الى العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم في ظل
اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بمحيط سلاح المدرعات بمنطقه جبرا جنوب
الخرطوم
ثم الى واشنطن وانعقاد قمه التي تبحث
استراتيجيات لمواجهه التهديدات المتزايده
على الامن السيبراني الامريكي
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
في احدث حلقات التصعيد في الضفه الغربيه
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقتل فلسطينيا
خلال اقتحام مخيم نور شمس بطول كرم واصابه
جنديه اسرائيليه في غور الاردن في عمليه
اطلاق نار تقول حماس انها رد على جريمه
جيش الاحتلال ضد النساء في الخليل
في اختراق محتمل للتصعيد بين اليامي
وباريس الكشف عن محادثات بين فرنسا
ومسؤولين في جيش النيجر لسحب بعض القوات
الفرنسيه
واشنطن تقول انها تركز على حل الدبلوماسي
وتبقي على دورها في مكافحه الارهاب
بالمنطقه والصين على الخط تعرض وساطه بحثا
عن تسويه تنهي الازمه
[موسيقى]
روسيا تعلن اسقاط مسيرات فوق موسكو والقرم
تعلن تقدما ميدانيا باتجاه ميلوتوبل جنوبا
وتنتقد تاخير تسليمها صواريخ المانيه
وامريكيه والبيت الابيض يحذر كوريا
الشماليه بانها ستدفع الثمن اذا زودت
روسيا باسلحه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد كنا قد
ناقشنا معكم على منصاتنا الرقميه تحقيقا
يكشف اجبار مجندات اسرائيليات نساء
فلسطينيات على خلع ملابسكن تحت التهديد
استطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي الاهداف
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من اجبار نساء
الفلسطينيات على خلع ملابسهم اما الاجابه
فكانت على النحو التالي
48% قالوا ان الهدف هو اذلال لاضعاف
المقاومه بينما قال اثنان وخمسون في المئه
ان الهدف هو تكريس الانتهاكات كامر واقع
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا ايضا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد
يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا في احدث حلقات
حملات الاعتقال الامن التونسي يعيد اعتقال
رئيس الحكومه السابق حماد الجبالي
[موسيقى]
قال بيان لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان
قواته قتلت فلس
من اصابه مجنده اسرائيليه خلال اشتباك قرب
قريه الزبيدات شمالي مدينه اريحا في غور
الاردن وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان المسلح
الفلسطيني فتح النار على قوته وتمكن من
اطلاق ثلاث رصاصات واصاب مجنده قبل ان
يتمكن بقيه الجنود الجنود من قتله كما
قالت المصادر بالجيش الاسرائيلي ان
التحقيقات كشفت ان عمليه اطلاق النار في
غور الاردن كانت هجوما مسلحا مزدوجا
هذا وقال الناطق باسم حركه حماس حازم قاسم
ان عمليه الاغوار الفدائيه تاتي ردا على
جرائم الاحتلال ضد الشعب الفلسطيني وخاصه
جريمته ضد النساء في الخليل بحسب وصفه
واضاف قاسم ان الشعب الفلسطيني ومقاومته
سيواصلان ضرباتهما ضد جيش الاحتلال
لتحليله ثمن جرائمه المتكرره
هذا وكاله تحقيق مشترك لمنظمه الاسرائيليه
وصحيفه هارت كشف ان 5 نساء فلسطينيات من
مدينه الخليل تعرضنا للتنكيل من قبل
مجلدات قمنا باجبارهن على خلع ملابسهم في
حادث وقع في العاشر من الشهر الماضي وقد
دعى نائب الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو الى التحقيق في الانباء المتداوله
عن انتهاكات قامت بها قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بحق نساء فلسطينيات في الخليل
البيوت الفلسطينيه قليلا ما نعرف حجم
الاجرام الذي يقع خلال الاقتحام جريمه
جديده تتجاوز كل الاعراف الاخلاقيه
والقوانين العسكريه ارتكبتها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فالضفه الغربيه
المحتله فلم تكتفي بانتهاك حرمات البيوت
بل تجاوزتها الى الخطوط الحمر
في الخبر الفضيحه الذي نشرتها ارريس مع
منظمه بيت سلم المعنيه بحقوق الانسان فان
50 جنديا اسرائيليا اقتحموا فجر احد ايام
شهر تموز يوليو الفائز منزل عائله
فلسطينيه من سته وعشرين فردا في مدينه
الخليل داخل المنزل بعد تحطيمه اتجهت
مجندتان صوب خمس سيدات فلسطينيات من
الاسره واجبرناهن على خلع ملابسهن والسير
عاريات امام اولادهن تحت تهديد الكلاب
البوليسيه المفترسه وقالت احدى الضحايا ان
الكلب اقترب منهن الى حد مخيف ولم يكتفوا
بذلك فقد اثبتوا انهم لصوص ارض ومال
فسرقوا مصاغا ذهبيا واموالا من داخل
المنزل اكثر من ذلك تقول منظمه ان الواقعه
ليست وحيده بل جزءا من سلسله وقائع يجري
فيها التنكي سيدات فلسطينيات ومحاوله
اهانتهن واذلالهن الخبر كان له وقع
الصاعقه على فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي توعدت قوات الاحتلال بالثار مثل ما
وصفت السلطه الفلسطينيه الواقعه بانها امر
فظيع ومخزن واثار الحدث عاصفه من الغضب
والشجب داخل فلسطين وخارجها بينما لم يصدر
تعليق عن جيش الاحتلال كان الفلسطينيون
وحدهم يعرفون ان ما جرى لا يمر دون عقاب
وانهم لا يسكتون عن المس بالارض وقبلها
العرض
معنا من رام الله دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
دكتور مصطفى في اي خانه تضع ما فعله
الجنود الاسرائيليون مع هذه الهائله مع
هؤلاء النسوه التي تقول التقارير بانها مع
سبق الاصرار والترصد ليس اقلها تصوير
هؤلاء النسوه بعد امرهن
بنزع ملابسهم
ما جرى هو جريمه [__] ووقعها لا توصف ومس
بالكرامه الانسانيه وعنف اجرامي عنصري جرى
فيه اعتداء ليس فقط جسدي بل نفسي ايضا على
النساء الفلسطينيات وعلى اطفالهن وعلى
عائلاتهم الذي جري جريمه فعلا
تجاوزت كل الخطوط الحمراء
واثارت غضب ليس فقط سكان الخليل بل اثارت
غضب كل الشعب الفلسطيني دون استثناء
وبالتاكيد سيكون لها تداعيات خطيره لن تمر
هذه الجريمه دون رد ولن تمر دون عقاب ولكن
الذي جرى ليس حادثه استثنائيه نحن وثقنا
من قبل عشرات الحالات التي تم فيها
استخدام الكلاب البوليسيه للاعتداء على
المتظاهرين حتى وهم عزا للاعتداء على
النساء للاعتداء على المواطنين
الاحتلال لا يتوقف عن ارتكاب كل هذه
السابقه
دكتور مصطفى فيما يتعلق بالامر بالنساء
بخلع ملابسهن الذي جرى بالتفاصيل هل هو
سابقه
هو سابقه من حيث استخدام الكلاب لاجبار
النساء على خلع ملابسهم وان كان ذلك ليس
الممارسه الاولى للاحتلال عشرات بل مئات
النساء الفلسطينيات تعرضنا للاجبارهن على
خلع ملابسهم على الحواجز وكذلك في
المطارات عندما
تصدف ان كانوا في المطارات الاسرائيليه
وعشرات المرات جرى فيها الاعتداء على
الرجال والنساء بهذا الشكل القبيح ولكن ان
تستخدم الكلاب بهذه الصوره الفجه امام
اطفال واجبار النساء على خلع ملابسهم
والسير عاريات امام اطفالهم هذا امر غير
مسبوق برايه وخطير جدا ولكن هي هو يدل على
مدى الوقاحه العنصريه التي وصل لها جيش
الاحتلال ومجرميه ومدى العنصريه
دكتور مصطفى باعتقادك
لا بالعكس هذا ليس سلوك فردي هذا سلوك
جماعي ومنظم ومتكرر من قبل جيش الاحتلال
الذي لا يحترم اي اعراف انسانيه على
الاطلاق وسيكون الرد عليه بالطريقه
الوحيده التي يفهمها الاحتلال وهو مقاومته
مقاومته بكل الاشكال ولكن السؤالين
الكبيرين هنا السؤال الاول كيف يصمت
العالم على كل هذه الجرائم تخيل لو كانت
هذه الجريمه ارتكبت في اوكرانيا مثلا ماذا
كان سيكون رد فعل بايدن وكل زعماء العالم
الغربي هل كانوا سيصمتون كما يصمتون اليوم
والسؤال الثاني كيف يمكن ان يسمح بتمرير
مثل هذه الجريمه والسكوت عليها من قبل كل
المدعين بالدفاع عن حقوق المراه في العالم
وعن حقوق النساء وعن حقوق الانسان هذا هو
السؤال الكبير على كل الشعب الفلسطيني
دكتور مصطفى ارجو ان تبقى معنا ساعود لك
ايضا نستعرض مجره في طولكرم حيث شيع
الاهالي جثمان الشهيد عايد ابو حرب الذي
قتلته قوه الاحتلال فرجع اليوم في
اشتباكات خلال اقتحامها مخيم نور شمس
وكانت قوه الاحتلال قد شرعت بمجرد دخول
المخيم في تدمير المنشات والمنى التحتيه
في هذا المخيم
حمل اسم عمه الشهيد عايد الذي استشهد قبل
ان يولد ابن اشهر والان التحق بضرب عمه
عايد ابو حرب من مخيم النور شمس في طولكرم
ام مكلومه وعائله تحاول التسلح بالصبر
الله يزيلها الظلم عنا لا يفجع عمي بولدها
يا رب قاعدين بياخذوا خيره هالشباب شباب
شايف هالظلم اللي احنا عايشينه غصب عنه
بده يثور بده يستغني عن الحياه اللي عايشة
مش حياه
شعارات تؤكد على مقاومه الاحتلال ورفض
الاستسلام هتفت بها حناجر المشيعين الذين
تقدمهم عشرات المقاومون
بعد الجنازه بدا الاهالي بتفقد اثار
الخراب الذي خلفه الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد ان
اقتحم المخيم بساعات بحثا عن عبوات ناسفه
جاهزه للتفجير حسب روايته
جرف شوارع ودمر منازل وعاف خرابا في محاله
تجاريه هي مصدر رزق وحيد لعائلات تعيش في
المخيم في ظل اوضاع اقتصاديه وانسانيه
صعبه يعني
زي ما تقولي دمار على الجميع وضمائر جماعي
ليس وحده عمر الذي يقول ان هذا الخراب هو
جزء من العقوبات الجماعيه بل اهالي المخيم
الذين يؤكدون ان الهدف من هذه العمليه هو
ضرب الحاضنه الشعبيه
للمقاومين نوجه الرساله انه احنا لا نحسك
الدمار يمتلك دمروا يخربوا يقتلوا الصغار
ذبحوا الكبار لا نخشاهم وجميعنا موحدين في
الميدان وسنبقى يد واحده
بالاحتلال تمديد من السلطه الوطنيه بسياسه
الاقتحامات عقب العمليه وتاكيد من الفصائل
كافه بان عمليات
لن تكسير المقاومه
مشاهد
يخلليات يرى كثيرون ان بعضها يهدف الى لفت
الانظار عن الخلافات الداخليه التي تمر
بها الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبعضها الاخر
موجه للمقاومه التي تؤكد انها ستواصل
التصدي لاي اقتحامات اسرائيليه للمخيمات
والمدن والبلدات الفلسطينيه
الجزيره من مخيم نور شمس طولكرم
دكتور مصطفى عاطفا على ما ذكرته الان في
اخر تقريرها جيفارا البوديري ما الذي
تريده الحكومه الاسرائيليه بكل ما تفعل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه حكومه عنصريه مجرمه
لا تريد ان يكون هناك اي فلسطيني في هذه
الارض
ولا تحترم اي حقوق للانسان الفلسطيني لا
تعتبرنا بشر اصلا وبالتالي ما تراه هو جزء
من الهجمه العدوانيه الصهيونيه المتسعه
التي تستهدف كل وجود الشعب الفلسطيني
وطبعا هم يريدوا ايضا ان يستفزوا الشعب
الفلسطيني بكل هذه الجرائم التي يرتكبونها
يعني عندما نرى اليوم فقدنا شهيدين غاليين
الشهيد محمد زبيداته عايد ابو حرب عايد
ابو حرب كما ذكرت تقرير عمه شهيد وسمي على
اسم عمه كان الفلسطيني يولد شهيدا
234 شهيد منذ بدايه هذا العام ومنهم 38
طفل احدهم محمد تميم لم يتجاوز عمره سنتان
ونصف الذي يقوم به الاحتلال هو عمليه بطش
وتنكيل وهو يقوم بذلك لان العالم يصمت على
جرائمه ولكن الشعب الفلسطيني يدرك ان الرد
الوحيد الذي يمكن ان يرضع هذا الاحتلال هو
مقاومته على الارض مقاومته بكل الوسائل
وبكل الاشكال واستنهاض اوسع حمله ممكنه
لفرض العقوبات والمقاطعه عليه وفضح جرائمه
التي لا تتوقف
من رام الله مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه شكرا جزيلا
لك
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه سنسلط الضوء على
مخيبات اللاجئين في الضفه الغربيه ونسال
ضيف الحصاد عن اسباب تصدرها التوتر
واستهدافها من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
قالت المصادر الدفاعيه فرنسيه ان مفاوضات
تجري بين عدد من ضباط الجيش في النيجر
وفارس حول الوجود الفرنسي العسكري في
اليامي ذات المصادر تقول انه من الممكن
اعاده نشر بعض هذه القوات في دول بالمنطقه
او اعادتها مباشره الى فرنسا خريطه الوجود
العسكريه الفرنسي في افريقيا نتابعها في
التقرير التالي
يجب على فرنسا ان تفتش على حلفاء جدد لها
في افريقيا يقول الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
فخارطه انتشارها العسكري في القاره تنحسر
بشكل لافت وكان باريس تدخل طور نقل جنودها
من دوله بات وجودهم بها غير مرغوب فيه الى
دول اخرى وجود القوات الفرنسيه في افريقيا
تعزز بعمليتي
اللتين تركزت في مالي وتشاد والنيجر
وبوركينا فاسو وموريتانيا وهدفتا الى
القضاء على من تسميهم فرنسا جماعات جهاديه
بدات متاعب فرنسا عام 2021 انقلاب في مالي
تضطر باريس على اثره الى سحب قواتها نقلت
فرنسا جنودها من قواعد مالي الى النيجر
لتطوى صفحه بارخان ثم اتى انقلاب بوركينا
فاسو عام 2022
حينها طلب زعيم المجلس العسكري الحاكم في
وجدوجو ابراهيم من القوات الفرنسيه مغادره
البلاد فانسحبت الى تشاد والنيجر ثم اهتزت
النيجر وبات على فرنسا ان تفكر بمصير
قواتها البالغ عددها
1500 جندي يتمركزون في ثلاث قواعد العاصمه
شمال العاصمه وايورو بالقرب من الحدود مع
مالي مصادر دفاعيه فرنسيه تحدثت عن
مفاوضات جاريه بين عدد من ضباط الجيش في
النيجر وباريس تقول المصادر انهم من
الممكن اعاده نشر بعض القوات في دول
بالمنطقه وخاصه في تشاد المجاوره او
اعادتها مباشره الى فرنسا وبهذا يتبقى
لفرنسا قرابه 6,000 جندي في افريقيا نحو
950 جنديا في تشاد ويعد الوجود الاقدم
المستمر لفرنسا في القاره قرابه 350 جنديا
في كل من الجابون والسنغال
1500 جندي في جيبوتي والذين يوفرون لباريس
موقعا استراتيجيا على البحر الاحمر كما
ينتشر 1700 جندي فرنسي في جزيره
مايوتلارينون في منطقه المحيط الهندي
[موسيقى]
معنا من ابو افولابي وهو الباحث في المركز
مركز الديمقراطيه والتنميه اهلا بك سيد
اذا ما تاكد خبر لومون بان هناك مفاوضات
بين باريس وضباط في الجيش النيجر من اجل
سحب تدريجي للقوات الفرنسيه من النيجر
وربما اعادتها الى باريس لنبدا فيما يتعلق
بالشان في النيجر ما دلاله هذه الخطوه على
الوضع في النيجر
بالفعل ان هناك
اعترافا متزايدا بالنسبه الى ما حصل في
النيجر والنقطه المهمه هنا هي ان الاعتراف
والاقرار هو باهميته المحادثات طبعا في
البدايه كان هناك مطالب عبرت عنها
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غربي افريقيا
وهددت بالتدخل العسكري وايضا فرنسا قالت
انها لا تعترف
بالعسكريين الذين انقلبوا على الرئيس
بازوم ولكن الان هذه المباحثات تؤشر الى
ان القوه الاستعماريه السابقه
اعترفت الان باكتمال عمليه الانقلاب وهناك
مباحثات تجري الان للمضيه قدما من خلال
التفاوضيه والحوار مع الس لطه الجديده
رغبه تاكيدا المصادر حسب الامود ان النقاش
كان باريس
وجيش النيجر ولم يكن مع اعضاء المجلس
العسكري الذي قاد الانقلاب فهل هذا
التفصيل يبقي على ما ذكرت الان بان هذا
بدايه اعراض او اقرار بالوضع الجديد في
النيجر
اذا هذا لا يغير اي شيء في حقيقه الاقرار
لان قياده الجيش في النيجر دعمت هذا
الانقلاب وعلى الولاء ودعمت موقف اللواء
اتياني وبالتالي هذا لا يغير اي شيء
بالنسبه الى المفاوضات
والحقيقه هي ان الرئيس بازوم لن يعود الى
سده الرئاسه هذا مؤشر بان الامور تتجه نحو
التفاوض وهناك مفاوضات ملموسه مع القياده
الجديده في النيجر وهذا ما نراه وهذا مؤشر
ان الجيش في النيجر يعمل على هذه النقطه
والامور لا تختلف سواء قالوا انهم يتحدثون
بشكل مباشر مع المجموعه التي قامت بهذه
العمليه او الجيش في هذه الحاله ماذا عن
التواجد الفرنسي برمته في المنطقه تتكلم
انه ربما يتم نقل هذه القوات الى تشاد
ولكن ايضا ربما تعود هذه القوات الى فرنسا
وبالتالي ماذا عن مستقبل الوجود العسكري
الفرنسي في كل هذه المنطقه باعتقادك
اعتقد انها لحظه مفصليه واساسيه بالنسبه
الى فرنسا لكي تعيد النظر في كيفيه
الانخراط مع النيجر نحن نعرف ان الرئيس
ماكرون بشكل عام تحدث عن ضروره اعاده
تحديد العلاقه ونسج العلاقه بين فرنسا
والدول المستعمره الافريقيه السابقه اذا
هناك ثلاثه رؤساء في فرنسا تعاقبوا وركزوا
على المقاربه الامنيه في النيجر في
البلدان الافريقيه ولكن الان نرى تغيرا
بهذا الاتجاه الاتجاه الجديد وراينا ما
حصل في مالي وفي بوركينا فاسو وفي غينيا
والان في النيجر اذا هناك اعاده دراسه
واعاده نظر في باريس لكيفيه الانخراط ونزل
علاقاتي مع الدول الافريقيه وحتى مع الدول
الافريقيه الصغيره نحن نتحدث عن نقطه
مفصليه واساسيه بالنسبه الى العلاقه بين
المستعمر الصادق فرنسا والدول المختلفه في
افريقيا من ابوجا افولابي الباحث في مركز
الديمقراطيه والتنميه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت
ثياب تحقيق تقدم باتجاه
الجنوبيه البلاد حديث يقابله وزير الدفاع
الروسي بنفي مطلق مشيرا الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لم تحقق اي تقدم منذ بدء
هجومها المضاد قبل ثلاثه اشهر في هذه
الاثناء قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها احبطت هجمات بالطائرات المسيره على
كل من موسكو وشبه جزيره القرم
مشهد مالوف فهذه اوكرانيا حيث الحرب تختبر
طول النفس كل يدعي الصمود ومراكبه المكاسب
في الميدان او هو اذا تعذر ذلك حديث عن
افشال خطه الطرف الاخر من ذلك مثلا قول
الروس انهم اسقط طائرات مسيره الاوكرانيه
كانت تهم بمهاجمه موسكو ومسيرات غيرها
كانت تحلق في اجواء شبه جزيره القرم
هناك جنوبا كثف الجيش الروسي هجماته
الجويه لكن الاوكرانيين يؤكدون احراز
قواتهم تقدما باتجاه ميليتوبول بوابه
القرن اخترقت تلك القوات اخيرا كما قالت
خط الدفاع الروسي الاول على جبهه
زابولوجيا ويبدو انها تستفيد الان في
تقدمها بما تراه ضعفا في تحصينات خط
الدفاع الثاني
هنا تقدم وهناك في ضخمه اخر بحسب هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه في طريق استعاده
المدينه المنشود اما في دونيتسك حيث عززت
القوات الروسيه مواقعها فتشير سلطاتها
الماليه لموسكو الى مقتل مدنيين في قصف
اوكراني على مدينتين في المقاطعه قد تشهد
تطورات الساعات الاخيره باستعاده كييف
زمام المبادره على الارض ربما كسب هجومها
المضاد فاعليه الاكبر مع وصول صواريخ
بريطانيه وفرنسيه بعيده المدى لكن الجدل
ما يزال محتدما بشان جديه الحلفاء
الغربيين في تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه قادره
على قلب معطيات الميدان لماذا يتاخر تعزيز
قدراتك يوم الدفاعيه السؤال مطروح في
المانيا التي توجه رئيسه لجنه شؤون الدفاع
في برلمانها اللومه الى المستشار الاف
شولز لا تفهم مارياجناس
عن تسليم صواريخ كروز الالمانيه من طراز
تاوروس الى اوكرانيا لعلها الخشيه من
امكانيه اطلاق الصواريخ الحديثه من
اوكرانيا لاصابه اهداف في الاراضي الروسيه
فهل هي ذاتها الدواعي التي تؤخر قرار
واشنطن بخصوص تزويد كييف بصواريخ ارض ارض
من نوع التعكمز الامريكيه هذه الصواريخ
التكتيكيه التي قد يصل مداها الى 300 كم
تعمل بالوقود الصلب وبالامكان اطلاقها من
انواع مختلفه من المنصات والقاذفات الصارو
خيه
يقول هؤلاء الاوكرانيون ان ذاك الصنف من
الصواريخ بامكانه انقاذ ارواح وانه هو ما
تحتاجه بلادهم لكسب الحرب وزاره دفاعهم
تطمئنهم بانها مساله وقت فالامريكيون كما
تؤكد كييف طلب تحليل بعض النقاط المتعلقه
بالطلب وباعداده
قال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ان
روسيا تجري محادثات متقدمه مع كوريا
الشماليه للحصول على اسلحه في حربها على
اوكرانيا واشار سولفا في مؤتمر صحفي الى
ان كوريا الشماليه ستدفع الثمن اذا زودت
موسكو باي اسلحه تتسبب في قتل الاوكرانيين
على حد تعبيره
تحليلنا الحالي يشير الى ان هناك مناقشات
متقدمه وناشطه بين كوريا الشماليه وروسيا
لتزويد موسكو بالاسلحه لاستعمالها في
اوكرانيا وراينا وزير الدفاع الروسي في
الاونه الاخيره يزور لطلب الاسلحه لدينا
ايضا معلومات تفيد بان زعيم كوريا
الشماليه يتوقع ان تجري هذه المباحثات على
مستوى القاده ندعو كوريا الشماليه الى
الوفاء بالتزاماتها العلنيه بعدم تزويد
روسيا بالاسلحه التي تتسبب في قتل
الاوكرانيين
من بيروت معنا العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك حضره العميد
الياس كيف تتحدث عن تقدم في ميلوتوبل وزير
الدفاع الروسي يتكلم على ان الهجوم المضاد
قد فشل وسائط محسوبه على روسي تتكلم عنها
حتى الدبابات المتطوره التي تم تزويد كيا
بها تم تدميرها من قبل القوات الروسيه هذا
يدفعنا لمحاوله فهم ما يجري الان
عبد القادر هناك خرق وليس بالخرق الكبير
لماذا لانه على المستوى التكتيكي هناك
عتاد ينقص القوات الاوكرانيه خاصه الذخيره
وخاصه كسحات الالغام وايضا حتى ولو حدث
هذا الخرق عبد القادر بالمطلق وبالمعنى
العسكري يجب توسيع هذا الكوريدور على
الاقل الى عرض ما يقارب العشره كيلومترات
لسببين اساسيين الاول لنقل المدفعيه التي
تدعم الجبهه الى الخطوط الاماميه والسبب
الثاني هو
لمنع قيام هجوم عكسي على المجنبه للقوات
المتقدمه وقطعها وبالتالي يفشل كل هذا
الموضوع ولكن هناك
حرب انفورميشن كما يقال حرب اعلاميه تقول
كذا وكذا وهذا الامر بعيد عن الواقع ولكن
دون شك التعزيزات
الروسيه التي اتت من ليمن هي تعزيزات مهمه
جدا وهذا الامر يعكس ان هناك شيء ما او
تخوف ما على جبهه واوريكيف
[موسيقى]
الاسرع والاسهل قدره على نقل هذه العتاد
هو الذخيره وهنا يبدو ان التصنيع الذخيره
اليوم هناك تراجع كبير في استعمال وانتاج
الذخيره خاصه ذخيره المدفعيه والصواريخ
ولكن الذي يساعد هذا الامر هو الحدود
المشتركه مع كوريا الشماليه ما يقارب سبعه
الى عشره كيلو متر وبالتالي القدره على
نقلها بالقطار الى الجبهه ولكن هذا الامر
يستلزم وقت اما الموضوع الاخر يعني ليس
هناك من تقنيات متقدمه يمكن لكوريا
الشماليه ان تعطيها لروسيه ولكن هذا امر
فريد من نوعه عبد القادر دوله عظمى تطلب
من دوله كانت تدعمها تقريبا فقيره ومعدومه
وحاصره من كل دول العالم ان تطلب هذه
المساعده في هذا الوقت الحساس باشارتك
للاسلحه المتقدمه او التقنيه لماذا الى
الان ما زالت كييف تعاتب حلفائها وتطلب
بتزويدها باسلحه معينه وما زال هناك
محاذير خاصه الاسلحه التي قد تصل العمق
الروسي
عبد القادر دائما دائما نتحدث عن المخزون
الاستراتيجي لهذه الدول على سبيل المثال
التوروس
الصاروخ الكروز الالماني الذي يصل مداه
الى 500 كيلومتر لدى المانيا 600 صاروخ
فقط منها 130 الى 300 جاهزه للاستعمال
ولكن تعودنا على سبيل المثال مع المانيا
ان تنتظر المانيا ما تقوله الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبعدها تذهب الى
الاعطاء هذا ما حصل مع الدبابات فاذا نحن
امام مرحله جديده في الصناعه حتى الغرب
يعاني من الصناعه او التصنيع العسكري
والذخيره اليوم تريد اوكرانيا هذه الذخيره
لدعم المجهود الحربي على جبهه ميليتوبول
ولكن هدف البعد العملاني ولكن الاهم كما
قلت في بدايه الحديث عبد القادر هو
المستوى التكتيكي الذي يحصل على الجبهه
والقتال المباشر
شكرا لك من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي
[موسيقى]
في احدث تطورات الملف التونسي قال فريق
الدفاع عن رئيس الحكومه التونسي السابق
حمادي الجبالي انه تم الافراج عنه وابقائه
على ذمه التحقيق بعد استجوابه لسبع ساعات
بينما نقلت رويترز عن مصادر بحركه النهضه
التونسيه قولها ان الامن التونسي اعتقل
رئيس حركه النهضه بالوكاله منذر
ومن جهتها قالت هيئه الدفاع عن المعتقلين
السياسيين فيما تعرف بقضيه التامر على امن
الدوله ان كل التهم الموجهه للمعتقلين
مفبركه وان ملف القضيه لا يحتوي على ادله
تدين المعتقلين وقال سمير ديلو عضو هيئه
الدفاع عن المعتقلين ان ايقاف المتهمين
كان بقرار سياسي
هواء الملف
يفسر
عدم خروج اي جهه رسميه
لتفسر سبب ايقافهم وسبب الابقاء على
ايقافهم وسبب التمديد على ايقافهم اربعه
اشهر بعد سته اشهر انقذت ما تم فيها كان
يكفي للقيام به اسبوعان او ثلاثه
لا شيء الا الرغبه فتشفي
معنى تونس محمد امين الجربي عضو تحالف
احرار ومن تونس سليم الحكيمي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكما ابدا بك سيد
محمد امين الجربي عن هذه الاتهامات بان
هذه التهم وملفات الاتهام انما هي ملفات
خاويه في مضمورها وانها اتهامات سياسيه هل
ترى كذلك
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام
لحد الان ننتظر فقط
هذه الوجهه نظره التي نقلتموها هي واجهه
هيئه الدفاع المتهمين ومن حقهم ان يروا
انهم متهمين بليله بان مده ان المتهم
والمتهم بريء حتى تثبت ادانته ولكن فقط
اذا كانت وزاره اذا كان وزاره العدل او
المحكمه في تونس
تمديدا الاحتفاظ بالمتهمين فهناك شبهه
ترقى الى قرينه وهي التي ادت الى
ادت الى تمديد الاحتفاظ بكل المتهمين والا
لما مثلا السيد حمادي الجبالي تم اليوم
بحثه ثم ثم عاد
طيب هذه نقطه مهمه سيد محمد دعاني اسال
انا ضيفي السيد سليم الحكيمي اطلاق حمادي
الجبالي اليس مؤشرا على ان هناك عداله
هناك تحقيق واذا لم يثبت شيء يتم اطلاق
سراحه وان كان ما زال او وضع تحت الاقامه
الجبريه
الحقيقيه هي تقوم على الاقلاع وليس وليست
التي تقوم على الاخطاء هذا هو جوهر
السياسي يعني وجرم جراني
الماضيه بانه له ورشه عمل لي اعداد
تفجيرات في حين انه كانت ورشه لتنظيم
مكيفات يعني لتركيب مكيفات حسب اختصاصي
يعني رئيس حكومه سابق يقوم بواسطه عمل
لصنع مكيفات ويعمل في عرق يستحق التكريم
ولا يستحق التخزين كما نشاهد ما هيك عن
هذه الايقافات هذا يندرج في اطار هرسله
دائمه وتخبط نظام تقريبا لم ينزل شيئا على
الصعيد على الصعيد الواقعي الانجاز الوحيد
هو الاعتقالات اعتقادات هي هذه الشخصيات
في حين انها اغلبها ليست شخصيات منافسه
على الحكومه في فرنسا المرشح يتقدم مرشحا
لمكروه قبل اربع سنوات من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه لا تقع هذه الاعتقالات
في الغرب يعني التونسيين اليوم لو خيطتهم
بين البقاء في تونس عن سفينه يرحل من كل
البلاد لوجد
وا ستحملهم لحمله لانه لا يوجد انجاز سوى
هذا الذي كنت اقوله لك رئيس قيس سعيد
عندما
السيد
بالعيد الرئيس حماد الزبيري هو الذي عين
قيس سعيد في هذه اللجنه التي لجنه الحكماء
التي عينه فيها ولكن هذا هو الان هو جزاؤه
يعني الان الدوله العميقه التي مكنت نفسها
من ما هو سياسي لمصالحها الخاصه هي في
التحكم في المشهد وتعتقد هذا ارجو ان تبقى
يا معي سيد سليم وكذلك سيد محمد محمد
السيد حمادي الجبالي هو الان موقوف على
ذمه التحقيق وليس تحت الاقامه الجبريه اذا
منذ تنظيم انتخابات المجلس الوطني
التاسيسي التونسي في اكتوبر 2011 وحتى
اعلام الرئيس قيس سعيد اجراءاته في الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو 2021 شهد تونس 9 حكومات
تناوب عليها سبعه رؤساء حكومه تعرض بعضهم
للملاحقات القضائيه او الاعتقال فيما بعد
تراس حمادي الجبالي الحكومه من ديسمبر
2011 حتى مارس 2013 وتعرض لملاحقه قضائيه
بتهمه تبييض اموال فيما يعرف بقضيه نماء
كما تعرض للسجواب فيما يعرف بقضيه تسفير
الى بؤر التوتر وقد تاجلت محاكمته بسبب
مرضه في ديسمبر 2022 واعتقل في الخامس من
سبتمبر الجاري ثم اطلق سراحه بعد ساعات
على ان يبقى على ذمه التحقيق تراس علي
العريض الحكومه من مارس 2013 حتى يناير
2014 وتعرض لملاحقه قضائيه في سبتمبر 2022
فيما يعرف بقضيه التسيير وقد اودع السجن
في ديسمبر من العام نفسه اما مهدي جمعه
فامتدت فتره رئاسته للحكومه من يناير 2014
حتى فبراير 2015
وتراس الحبيب الصيد فترتين متتاليتين
كرئيس للحكومه من فبراير 2015 حتى اغسطس
2016 اما يوسف الشاهد الذي تراس الحكومه
فترتين متتاليتين ايضا فبقي في المنصب من
اغسطس 2016 حتى فبراير 2020 ويواجه
ملاحقات قضائيه في قضايا فساد والتامر على
الدوله وقد غادر تونس الى فرنسا في نوفمبر
2021 ثم تولى الياس الفخفاخ رئاسه الحكومه
من فبراير 2020 حتى سبتمبر من العام نفسه
وقد واجه ملاحقه قضائيه في شبهه تضارب
مصالح عام 2020 وتم التبريئاته العام
الماضي وتولى هشام المشيشي رئاسه الحكومه
في سبتمبر 2020 حتى انهى الرئيس سعيد
حكومته بالاعلان عن اجراءاته في الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو 2021
سيد محمد الجربي ضيفي من تونس هذه
الملاحقات المتتاليه لمعارضي الرئيس قيس
سعيد وعلى راسهم القيادات في حركه النهضه
هل قدمت اي جديد على صعيد هذه الملفات
يمكن ان يبرر كل هذه الملاحقات التي طارت
كلها هؤلاء الناس
فقط فلنقل فقط اذكر السيد سليم ليست ليس
من فراغ يتم لاحقا قضائيه هنا لقد هناك
هناك في العشريه السوداء الذي هناك صارت
هناك صارت تسير هناك فساد اقتصادي وهناك
واذكر
التسريب الذي
لم يتسحر بين رئيس حركه النظر بالنيابه
وبين احدى الصحافيات يؤكد الفساد الذي
كانت تدار به الدوله والذي كانت والذي كان
يدير به الصف الاول من حركه النهضه هذه
البلاد اذا هذه الملفات على الاقل هناك
شبهات لننتقل
ولكن القضاء سياخذ مجراه اذا كل من افسد
في هذه البلاد يجب ان يعاقب
فلنذكر اعيد سؤال
محمد الجردي هل قدمت هذه الملاحقات منذ
فتح الرئيس قيس سعيد حتى الان اي نتيجه
تدلل وتثبت حقيقه او جدوى او الدعوه لهذه
الملاحقات
نحن نعرف ان الزمن القضائي لا يساوي
الزمان السياسي لاثبات اي دعوه قضائيه
هناك 14 شهرا اولا في طور التحقيق ولحد
الان الموقوفون لم ينهوها ثم ياتي ثم
نحن لا نقول
المذنبون ام مدنون حتى يبت في علم القضاء
ولا نافقه كامله في القضاء التونسي اذا
بذكرك للثقه في القضاء التونسي اسال السيد
سليم الحكيمي مع دون نتكلم عن قضايا قضايا
هي مفتوحه امام العداله وامام القضاء اذا
لماذا الاحتجاج لماذا الاعتراض لماذا هذا
التسيس في طرح هذا الملف
يعني اليوم علامه
الامارات السيد حمادي
الذين لهم جنسيه
ولا يقبل الا على رؤس
اء الحكومه المشاركه رمزيه يعني يوسف غشاء
الذين كنت تعرض
ونه الحركه التيار الاسلامي شارك مشاركه
رمزيه سنه 2014 يعني المفارقه الكبرى اقل
الناس
خسرت الدوله الان قضيتها في الغرب وخسرت
تونس وخمسه مليار دولار تقريبا
يعوده ونعوضه بالايقافات في الداخل يعني
عوض ان نقف سرات الحقيقيين في البلاد لكن
نحن نخلع لتوجيه الدوله تقريبا العميقه
التي توجه نح
و الاسامي نستغل هذا هو التحرير الاعلامي
الذي وقع عليهم
وبالمناسبه التيار الاسلامي يتحمل
المسؤوليه لانه وضع نفسه ان كانت له جريره
حقيقيه وجريرته انه لم يحاسب الفاسدين
وتسامح معهم وهو الان يجني ثمار هذا
التسامح التي قام عليها حكمه والان الان
يعودون الى سجون
بفضها
اذا كانت الحرب هي
اذا كانت الحقيقه او ضحايا الحرب فان
الدوله القانون هي اول السلطاني ما يجري
في تونس لا يشرف السياسه من تونس
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي شكرا لك وكذلك
لضيف من تونس ايضا محمد امين الجربي عضو
تحالف احرار شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
بدات في واشنطن اعمال قمه
السنويه الرابعه عشره للامن السيبراني
بمشاركه مسؤولين حكوميين وشخصيات بارزه في
مجال الامن السيبراني وتسلط القمه التي
تستمر اربعه ايام الضوء على قضايا
سيبراليه تهدد الامن القومي وكيفيه عمل
القطاعين العام والخاص لمعالجه هذه
التهديدات ومن المتوقع ان تجذب هذه القمه
نحو 2000 مشارك واكثر من 200 متحدث من
بينهم مديره الاستخبارات القوميه
حديث الامن السيبراني يمتد من الولايات
المتحده الى القاره الاوروبيه فبعد الكثير
من الجدل والمخاوف اعلنت شركه تيك توك
الصينيه انشاء مركز تخزين بيانات في
ايرلندا في محاوله لتهدئه المخاوف اوروبا
بشان خصوصيه البيانات
هاجس الامن السيبراني يرخي بظلاله من جديد
وفي محاوله لخفض التوتر تعلن تيك توك
الصينيه انشاء مركز لتخزين البيانات في
ايرلندا استجابه لمخاوف اوروبيه بشان
خصوصيه البيانات
المنصه الصينيه التي تلاحقها اصابع
الاتهام من الولايات المتحده ودول اوروبيه
اكدت ان عمليه ترحيل بيانات المستخدم
الاوروبي الى مركزها قد بدات بالفعل وهي
العمليه التي ستشرف عليها شركه ان سي سي
جروب للامن السيبراني البريطانيه
عمليه ستعزز وفق الشركه بمركز ثان في
ايرلندا وثالث في النرويج قبل نهايه العام
المقبل ارتباط تيك توك بالصين جعله في
مواجهه الشكوك والانتقادات اذ يتهم منتقد
التطبيق الذي يتيح مشاركه مقاطع الفيديو
القصيره بانه يمنح السلطات الصينيه
امكانيه الوصول الى بيانات المستخدمين في
جميع انحاء العالم هذا الاتهام ان فته تيك
توك المملوكه لشركه باي دانس الصينيه
مرارا وفصلت نفسها عن بيجين خلال الدفاع
عن نفسها مؤكده ان جميع بيانات المستخدم
مخزنه بشكل امن في سنغافوره والولايات
المتحده في المقابل كانت ولايه مونتانا
الامريكيه قد اقرت قانونا يحضر التطبيق
منذ مطلع العام الجاري ويتوقع ان تحذو حذو
مونتانا ولايات اخرى كما منعت الحكومات
الامريكيه والكنديه والبريطانيه
والاستراليه وكذلك
المفوضيه الاوروبيه مسؤوليها من تحميل
تطبيق تيك توك على هواتفهم المخصصه للعمل
وبنظام حمايه البيانات هذا الذي يتخذ
عنوان مشروع كلوفر تحاول منصه تيك توك
امتصاص ضغط اوروبا التكتل الذي يفرض
قوانين صارمه بشان الخصوصيه
[موسيقى]
من اجل ضرب المقاومه وفصل الضفه الغربيه
عن قطاع غزه المحاصر تكرروا اسرائيل
عملياتها في مخيمات اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
بالضفه اذ اصبحت المخيمات العنوان الابرز
لموجه التوتر غير المسبوقه منذ سنوات في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وبؤر الصراع الاولى
ويتوزع في الضفه الغربيه 19 مخيما يقتله
ما يزيد عن 800 الف لاجئ فلسطيني بحسب
سجلات وكاله الامم المتحده لغوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
وبينما انتشرت في الضفه الغربيه بشكل لافت
منذ بدايه عام 2022 مجموعات للمقاومه تبنت
عمليات بارزه ضد اهداف اسرائيليه فان
مخيمات اللاجئين تعد القاعده والحاضره
الرئيسيه لتلك المجموعات على سبيل المثال
مخيم جنين للاجئين برزت كتيبه جنين
المحسوبه على حركه الجها الاسلاميه وتضم
مسلحين من عده فصائل اما في مخيم بلاطه في
نابلس فانطلقت عرين الاسود وكتيبه بلاطه
وتحظى هذه المقاومه بدعم شعبي واسع داخل
مخيمات اللاجئين وكذلك خارج هذه المخيمات
مخيم نور شمس بضواحي مدينه طولكرم وبه
اشتدت منذ اكثر من عام حاله المقاومه على
ايدي المجموعات الفلسطينيه المختلفه ويبلغ
عدد سكان المخيم نحو 11 الف نسمه الف
يعيشون في مساحه لا تتعدى
232 دونما
كانت ولا تزال المخيمات الفلسطينيه كما
ذكرنا تاريخيا الاكثر حضورا في الفعل
الشعبي والفعل المقاوم ضد اسرائيل ومن
امثله ذلك مخيم جنين كما ذكرنا ومخيم
جباليا الذي اندلعت منه الانتفاضه الاولى
عام
1987 تصعيد العدوان الاسرائيلي على تلك
المخيمات وان فشل في اضعاف المقاومه الا
انه تسبب في خسائر في الارواح
والممتلكات استشهد اكثر استشهد اكثر من
200 فلسطيني منذ بدايه 2023 وفق احصائيات
رسميه غالبيتهم العظمى في الضفه الغربيه
وتحديدا في مخيمات اللاجئين خلال عمليات
مداهمه شبه يوميه للجيش الاسرائيلي كان
العام 2022 سجل
استشهادئين
فلسطينيا من بينهم 171 في الغربيه ومنذ
بدايه هذا العام العام الجاري 2023 شهدت
مدينه جنين ومخيمها نحو 20 نشاطا عسكريا
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي تراوحت بين اقتحام
واسع وكذلك عمليات خاطفه في التاسع والعشر
التاسع عشر عفوا ملي يناير كانون الثاني
اقتحمت قوه خاصه مخيم جنين ثم تابعتها نحو
70 اليه عسكريه واسفر الاقتحام عن استشهاد
ادهم جبارين من قاده كتيبه جنين وكذلك
مواطن اخر بالاضافه الى اصابه عشره اخرين
في تاريخ اخر في الثالث من يوليو تموز شن
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اوسع عمليه عسكريه
على جنين ومخيمها منذ عام
2002 متابعه لهذا الملف عن هذه الحاله بين
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبين المخيمات معنا
من جنين
ايمن يوسف استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه العربيه الامريكيه سيد ايمن
هذا الفعل الاسرائيلي حيال هذه المخيمات
هل هو رد فعل على تنامي ظاهره المقاومه
داخل هذه المخيمات ام يدخل ضمن مخطط هو
لازاله بشكل كامل للتواجد الفلسطيني
مساء الخير استاذ عبد القادر
المشاهدين انا اعتقد انه في هناك حاله
نضاليه فلسطينيه تحتضنها مخيمات الضفه
الغربي على وجه التحديد ويبدو ان كره يعني
النضال والنار يعني تتدحرج من مخيم الى
اخر من مخيم جنين الى نور شمس الى اكبر
جبر الى بلاطه الى مخيمات جنوب الضفه
الغربيه هذه الحاله النضاليه انا برايي
يعززها ثلاث عوامل هامه العامل الاول
اللاجئون الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربي وفي
كل مخيمات الوطن والشتات يمثلون الروايه
هم يتناقلون الروايه الوطنيه من الاباء
والاجداد الذين تم اقتلاعهم من اكثر من
500 قريه فلسطينيه في الساحل وفي الداخل
الفلسطيني وبالتالي هم حريصون تماما على
التمسك بحق العوده
وجعل يعني نار الوحده الوطنيه وشعله
النضال يعني
متوقده ومتقده لذلك انا برايي يعني هذه
الروايه في نفوسهم ويتورطونها من الاباء
الى الاجداد العامل الثاني الطبيعه
الديموغرافيه والجغرافيه للمخيمات يعني
الاف اللاجئين الفلسطينيين يعيشون في بضع
في في بعض من الداع يعني اقتصاديه
اجتماعيه معقده يعيشون على المساعدات
المباشره من الاوروبا ومن الدول الثانيه
لذلك هذا انا برايي ولا رده فعل يعني عنيف
لدى هؤلاء الناس وبالتالي وصلوا الى قناعه
ان الحل الافضل والحل الكريم هو فعلا
التمسك بحل يعني بحق العوده ومحاوله
الوصول الى حياه افضل العامل الثالث
المخيمات الفلسطيني في الضفه الغربيه
تعالت على جراح الانقسام واسست غرف عمليات
مشتركه وهذه انا برايي نقطه في غايه
الاهميه استراتيجيا وامنيا كل فصائل العمل
الوطني والاسلامي متوحده داخل المخيمات
تنسق عملياتها وحتى تنسق مع العمليات
الفرديه لذلك انا بعتقد حتى وان كان هناك
خطه اسرائيليه لاطلاع اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين ومحاوله تهجيرهم مره اخرى من
داخل المخيمات الى المدن والارياف
الفلسطينيه الا انه نحن لا نركن انه هناك
حاله
عن هذه الخطه التقارير اعلاميه اسرائيليه
تتكلم عن مدى تاثير وزير الماليه على
تفكير رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو فلسفه
القائمه على ما سماه ربما الحل النهائي اي
لا وجود للفلسطينيين ولا تمييز في تصفيه
الفلسطيني سواء كان طفلا او امراه او غير
ذلك
وبالتالي في ظل هذه المقاربه ومن نشاهده
من سلوكات من قبل جيش الاحتلال حياله هذه
المخيمات هل تلمسون هذا التوجه
يعني هذا هذا موجود على ارض الواقع يعني
اقتحام المخيمات بشكل منتظم
يعني من خلال طائرات الدرون
والاعتقال والقتل المتعمد هذا طبعا يثير
حاله من الخوف والغضب لدى السكان المحليين
داخل هذه المخيمات وبالتالي ممكن يكون
هناك محاولات فعلا للخروج من المخيم
والبحث عن ملادات امنه لكن يبقى اللاجئ هو
لاجئ يعني في الحاله الفلسطينيه اللاجئ هو
لاجئ حتى وان ابتدع عن ابتعد عن جغرافيه
المخيم تبقى قضيه النضال يعني في عقله وفي
قلبه وفي وجدانه لذلك اعتقد في هناك خطه
اسرائيليه وفي تفكير اسرائيلي لكن انا
بعتقد لم ينجح النتيجه لتشبث هؤلاء الناس
يعني بروايتهم في هناك التحام ايضا مع
المدن الموجودين فيها في عنا 19 مخيم
حوالي 900 الف لاجئ فلسطيني هم ملتحمين في
الحال النضاليه مع المدن الموجودين حولها
ومع الريف الفلسطيني الممتد وبالتالي انا
براي هم وقود معركه مشتعلي بدات تتدحرج في
الضفه الغربيه طبعا تدعمها ظروف اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه وسياسيه في غايه التعقيد
وبالتالي وبالتالي انا برايي نحن امام
ظاهره راح تتطور اكثر وراح يكون الها ربما
تداعيات وربما تدفع الحاله الفلسطيني الى
سوناريوهات ربما يعني اكثر خطوره
بالمواجهه من جنين ايمن يوسف استاد العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العربيه الامريكيه
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
نختم هذا الحصاد بجدل لم يتوقف في فرنسا
عنوانه حظر ارتداء العباءه في المدارس
تشير ارقام رسميه نشرت اليوم الى ان نحو
300 طالبه من اصل 12 مليون بداوا العام
الدراسيه هذا الاسبوع حضرنا بالعباءه الى
المدارس وتمت اعادته 67 منهن الى المنازل
بسبب رفضهن
الامتثال لقرار الحكومي رحب به اليمين
الفرنسي لكن اليسار قال انه يمس الحريات
المدنيه ويخفي مشاكل اكثر الحاحا في
التعليم الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
يقول ان القرار يهدف الى الدفاع عن
العلمانيه ومبادئ الجمهوريه لكن المجلس
الفرنسي للديانه الاسلاميه اعتبر اليوم ان
الحضره الاخير للعباءه في المدارس في
فرنسا تعسفي ويخلق مخاطر عاليه للتمييز ضد
المسلمين واضاف ان العباءه لم تكن ابدا
زين او دليلا دينيا وحظر وتقييد باسم مبدا
العلمانيه سنتابع حلقاته المتكرره في
الايام القادمه
كتاب الحصر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]